okay so let's remember when you're
graphing an inequality any inequality
whether it's on number one or another
plane okay you get your boundaries by
taking the inequality and just making it
equals right okay so our boundary will
look like this and this hopefully is a
graph a function that you're very
familiar with right looks like okay by
the way this has a name it's called a
hyperbola and it's plural is hyperbola
lay not to be confused with the method
starting up method the technique from
English or say you know I hate 10 horses
in English Maths right anyway here's my
army here's my graph okay now I'm going
to include my asymptotes in here right
because these asymptotes they define the
boundaries okay so I need to have the
mail okay so here's y equals zero here's
X equals zero and he is matters now I
think we mentioned before when we were
talking about functions a particular
category of function which is ones which
have discontinuities discontinuities to
remember that really important work this
graph has a discontinuity so another way
we're saying is it has two branches
right is the bike a branch and the left
hand branch now because of these the
duality on that right or if there were
three branches are for right each branch
has its own set of rules for its
inequality so when we test the point
test a one point will not do you've got
two tests well one for each branch okay
so how is this way let's think about
point in this case unfortunately we can
treat the origin because it makes your
right or your inequality right so let's
pick a point like say 1 0 there test 1 0
as we put it in we get Y sine we get 0
is greater than or equal to 1 over 1 is
this true let me make it more obvious is
this true yeah think hard
ok so seeing as this is not this point
is not in the in the region I want to
shake okay so you look carefully all
right
the way these inequalities work right
they're greater than or less than n that
means above or below right so instead of
being that's what it's better to think
about above or below than left or right
left or right will confuse you
this is below and it's not part of the
region okay so therefore I want a bump
so I'll get my color and I'll show you
okay so there's above right now when I
have a look at the other branch right
this is just one branch okay I've got to
test in another point which is either
above or below the other branch does
that make sense so that's why this point
relates this branch I need to pick
another one like say minus 1 0 which is
over there so when I test this one minus
1 0 I get 0 is greater than 1 or
negative 1 is it true yes so this point
is in the river right now because it
just deals with the left hand branch
right
that's why when I shade this like so the
important thing to get is that it
doesn't cross the y-axis see that stops
because there's a discontinuity doesn't
break over and like take over this
region here we know it can't because we
just tested that point and it's not in
the region doesn't satisfy the Equality
okay does that make sense so when you're
working out okay where are my boundaries
here when you've got this given to
continuities you just gotta be more
careful for each branch test the point
tested above or below and then you're
okay why I thought so I always start off
drawing my um my boundaries dotted
because if I've got one or more right
I'm not sure which parts of it will be
okay in which parts 1 now promise true I
mean there's only one here okay but I
default to putting them as da nerd
because then the parts that I want to be
filled I can fill and I don't have to
run that okay but I should point out um
since that's the only inequality I'm
interested in I do include the batteries
okay done
now I just want to show you one more
example which is not on your sheet which
is a semicircle
that's good that's good
okay sorry I confuse myself when I drew
a circle the first time all right
this inequality hopefully you can
recognize will be a semi circle because
you've got your square root there and
there's a square underneath and so on
okay so what can I deal with this as I
expand it because the semicircle right I
know it's going to be half of a circle
so let's just keep this in mind I'll
write on the top volume and I wonder if
you can remember you remember we were
dealing with semi circles there are four
kinds of semi circles right there's the
top one there's a bottom one left and
right I don't say it yet but just think
about the world okay which one is this
all right the reason why you have to
think about it now is because I'm about
to take the boundary square out
everything when you square it you lose
which side it is right you don't know
which one is you just get the whole
circle okay so keep that in mind for now
let's take the boundary
the battery will be y equals one plus
the square root of 1 minus X minus 1
whole square okay so if I want to spined
out what's circle this came from right I
want to get it back into general form
yeah so I'll kick this minus 1 is 1 very
few so it becomes a minus 1 okay now I
can square so y minus 1 whole square and
then I'm 3 my X minus 1 squared side and
now I can recognize the features of this
right okay
I can now read off because in general
form right I can say the center of this
stuff is as all right so now I can start
to draw this I can say my set term will
be now do you did you work out is it top
or the bottom or the left or the right
it's the top how do you know
okay so seeing as this is plus square
root right you're gonna go in for one
think about this way right one will be
the lowest value you can get right
because this square everything the
smallest at the kingdom is zero right
it can't go negative so I'm gonna go to
one and up right and since the center is
one I cut and I'm going one and up I
can't get the bottom of the circle okay
so good logic good let's join us what
does this semi circle look like it's
gone right okay there's the semi circle
now before I said a more intuitive way
of thinking about circles and the
inequalities they give you right is that
you're either inside a circle or outside
the circle right inside or outside okay
and that was when you've got the whole
circle right because it's it's a sort of
closed system if you likes you either in
or out but if you think about the semi
circle right well let's test a point
shall we and we'll see where we going
let's test the Centaur cuz that's nice
and easy okay one one when you put it in
test what's gonna happen I'll have one
on my inside so that's then one plus the
square root of one minus xever
right so you got 1 is less than 1 plus
the square root of 1 so 1 is less than 2
looks good yeah so the center is in if I
just take that hot inside the semi sir
okay just like we were inside the circle
right like so we've actually missed a
whole bunch hold the pot of the region
because remember how I was trying to
draw your attention here right to the
fact that really rather left or right
it's that up or down
so that's why this goes all the way up
all the way up it's exactly the same
deal here right so you've got this we
looking up right and it's above or below
not inside outside okay
so that's a bit confusing when you've
got a circle it's it's that where you
got a semicircle it's moping doubt right
that's just a point like say what's that
one zero okay this x-value affects the
right hand side right so I'm gonna get
two on the right hand side just like I
got before and on the left hand side I
just have one so I'll have zero is less
than two does that work sure does right
so this part even though it's not inside
the semicircle is a pattern you can keep
on testing I'm not above I'm okay
so the keeps on going now I'll be
careful
right I suppose we may really think
about this is discontinuous because look
f is a break
right but this semicircle doesn't exist
everywhere so what happens to values
like over here and over here what do you
think a major should ask are they
included or not they're not included
it is only underneath here so actually
I'm gonna have to introduce a new
boundary yeah here and okay so I guess
this boundary would be x equals two
right and this one would be X zero but
why can't I go outside what happens if I
go outside put in values like s equals
three you put you put a value in you'll
see what happens right I'm gonna get one
minus and then this thing will start
growing in size so I'm gonna get the
negative values under the square root
okay
now later on you're seeing negative
values under the square root they have a
meaning but not on this graph okay we're
really interested in the real numbers
not the imaginary ones okay therefore
make sure you catch the whole thing okay
goes all the way down and of course if I
flip this inequality and said greater
than okay it'll be all the ones above
now wonder if you've noticed the pattern
yet maybe you this is the way you
thought about it if you've got an
inequality which has Y on one side on
its own okay
y on one side on its own you're greater
then you're about sequels that if you're
less than now sometimes people get
confused by that in the caramel which is
which which is why we encourage you to
test the point is testing a point is
okay and you can know with certainty and
not be like yeah
the whole way I think it's safer
probably to always label as an equation
the reason being all the other
boundaries that I have will always be
equations right so this is one plus
right so I feel like it's kind of neat
to have one room for one boundary and it
difficult for the others
because it is a vertical line which is
sort of a special case I think you could
probably get away with it to say - right
but I mean on my graph I draw that do
you draw the whole thing I put it on
because that line x equals 2 does
actually go on forever it's only
relevant er but the violent selfies you
know so I don't think it matters that
much to be honest